so you all see this big link on here
hopefully you can see it in the back of
the room this is just a gotomeeting that
will show you guys the code and the
slides and stuff that I will be going
through this is so you all can hopefully
see it because I'm going to be in them
for about 25 minutes of this and it
might be a little bit on the small side
so if you're having trouble seeing the
screens feel free to hop into this its
tiny URL com / you to dash can dash
believe it's gotomeeting just put it in
your name and it will pop up go to
meeting some of your web developers and
saying I don't want to install
gotomeeting that's okay I understand
that just if you don't mind straining
your eyes so thanks for coming out to my
talk where I hope that with this one
weird way to rewrite closures I can
restore your faith in native JavaScript
closures the rest of this time don't
believe anything I say that is my only
caveat so with that before we get into
the mind blowing business I'll tell you
just a quick little bit about myself I'm
Jonathan Martin I work at the big nerd
ranch up in Atlanta Georgia and I work
as a backing in front end developer and
also as an instructor if you happen to
be up near the Atlanta campus we'd love
to have you we probably have some swag
at the end of this talk Todd in myself
who also works at big nerd ranch at the
front table we will be out at one of the
booths or tables out there if you're
interested in getting any koozies or
nerdy glasses any of that stuff we have
it all so everyone nowadays when they
talk about JavaScript they talk about
scopes and closures as being the big
thing that make JavaScript so powerful
but really for years people have
survived without this memory intensive
complication on the JavaScript runtime
anytime you need to avoid variable name
shadowing or global or any kind of
variable name collisions all you needed
to do was use unique global variable
names maybe you prefix your variable
names with some unknown unheard-of
function name there's all kinds of
techniques people used so the example I
give first of all his Fortran Fortran
introduced in 1957 that was back when a
corrupted computer program probably
meant you got mustard or something on
your punch card Oh nowadays we don't
have that excuse for corrupted program
but considering that we still to this
day rely on all these super optimized
mouth algorithms that are written in
Tran I'd say they did pretty well
without any sort of local variables or
closures then x86 assembly 1978 in my
opinion one of the first real languages
because you could write hello world and
other insignificant things like
operating systems in it they did all
this just fine without any concept of
closures or local variables all that's
just kind of modern propaganda that gets
thrown at us all day even ruby ruby was
introduced in 1995 and we all know it
really just came as a last ditch effort
to save object-oriented programming in
the wake of the closure craze well
thanks to Ruby object-oriented
programming apparently lives on and
people still right things with classes
instead of closures which is totally the
way to do it nowadays but apparently
that's frowned upon by Twitter so to the
point you don't actually need closures
or local variables or any of that
nonsense however closures 10 because
they were attacked on at the last minute
into JavaScript they're slower than a
java GUI so we spend most of our time
waiting for closures to execute we have
the sink called function overhead
because it's got to initialize all these
variables on a stack all this nonsense
attached the functions when really it
would be so much faster if we could do
this all on the heat all at runtime
dynamically so typically when we want to
improve these sorts of things we rewrite
them so reacts virtual Dom comes to mind
it completely rewrote the DOM and
completely replaces it so you don't need
the Dom anymore and it makes everything
so much faster well what if we did the
same thing with closures because who
here has used the closure who here has
used local variables so you guys are
probably plaguing ninety-nine point nine
percent of your code with this memory
intensive complication on the runtime
engine it's all nonsense back in the day
we just use global variables which
really just registers registers are
about as fast as you can get it's only
one or two machine instructions away so
to address the underlying performance
problems in JavaScript we just need to
replace it entirely ourselves and we're
going to rewrite it all by yourself and
by the way this will also give us a
chance to completely redo the syntax
because I mean really who remembers the
VAR keyword every time without days
hence not-so-subtle products so in the
spirit of IE compatibility modes we are
going to develop our own
we fill for those clouds your closure
bounds developer friends of ours who are
still stuck in all this pure function
and Y Combinator propaganda who knows
where it came from and we're going to
bring them back to the simplicity of
global variables and registers all in
JavaScript now before we go on this
little journey we do have some rules we
have to follow otherwise it would just
be a free-for-all so any code that is
going to be using this polyfill has to
do five things first off it is not
allowed to use any native local
variables it is not allowed to use
native local variable assignment or
create functions with parameters or any
sort arguments now those of you who are
used to doing parameters it's really
just local variables after all inside
the function that get bound to some
value so that's the local variable in
and of itself will still have slow
functions so we're going to nuke all of
that you can't do any of that in your
coat however the implementation as we
will see is allowed to use some of those
second you may not attach any data
directly to a function object know sort
of memoization no cache objects none of
that functions are going to be a music
or the terminology we'll see as a music
function body we are allowed to do a few
things we are allowed to access that one
weird global variable and then we can
use a music function bodies just to wrap
around buckets of code again these
buckets of code are not allowed to use
local variables of any sort or
parameters so I call them in music
because they don't remember anything
about their scoping rules which are
built into JavaScript they're not
allowed to do any of that so they will
be a music just buckets of statements
and then finally just to make things a
little bit shorter for demo you are
allowed to use shortcut local variables
that will give you access to a few
functions as we will see later on
because they could just be expanded to
the full global variable name some of
you may remember this convention if you
watch programming with nothing you
mentioned at the beginning of the talk
so that takes a similar convention where
you can use constants just to simplify
the code but at the end it can all be
collapsed and not even use any sort of
local variable names so we're going to
do all that so with these rules we're
going to make substitutions like this
the first line you see is VAR local
equals some value this is going to be
replaced with
mysterious function called s as for set
it will take in the name of a local
variable to which we want to assign and
then that value so s will exactly
replace the variable assignment we're
used to anytime we want to do a lookup
we call g which is 4g forget which takes
in the name of the local variable and
just returns the value in the current
scope exactly the same as variable look
up and anytime we have a function
expression assigned to a variable we
will replace all of that with a call to
F F takes in the name of the local
variable to which we would be assigning
this function the list of parameters as
an array and then that amnesic function
body notice that the function body has
no parameters it's not allowed to do
this we're just using functions as a way
to wrap around a bunch of code so with
this in mind we're going to take an
example that looks like this this is a
canonical example of how closures work
in JavaScript in this case we have an
outer function which when invoked
returns an inner function which when
invoked prints out the values of x y and
z now the prudent among you will notice
that the inner function shadows the x
variable of the outer one so if you were
to evaluate what that bottom statement
would run it would execute outer passing
in 1 and 2 and inner passing in three
and four and you should get an output of
3 comma 2 comma 4 because it prints out
X and X is shadowed so the second time
we pass in the value of x into the inner
function that's going to be what gets
printed so remember the output of this
should be 3 comma 2 comma 4 and with our
little transformation we saw in the last
slide we're going to make this look so
much better we're going to replace it
with this will call our f function or g
function in our s function so notice in
here there is no reference to native
local variables or functions with
parameters all we have are those three
setter getter and function helpers so
bear this in mind as we start developing
it because the next step is to in 70
lines of code we're going to
re-implement this and all will be
exposing our that s f and g functions so
at this point i'm going to move to
something very risky we're going to live
code this in them
first difficulty we will face is getting
this large enough to see I need another
screen so if you guys can't read this
especially as you get back a few rows go
ahead and go a launch up that
gotomeeting I know it's a plug-in who
wants a plug-in but WebRTC won't work on
these firewalls unfortunately so you
should be able to follow along then so
I'm going to be taking a test driven
approach to doing all this which means
I've cheated before hand I've written
out all these specs which describe this
behavior that I want out of this i'm
using mocha and chai okay i have not yet
been instructed on the proper
pronunciation so first off we're going
to look at how a scope should work for a
global context so whenever you think
about scopes we're thinking about local
variables back in the days of x86 and
fortran all you had was the global scope
variables that can be accessed from
anywhere in your program so it's very
easy to describe these so let me walk
you through it first off we have a
little bit of setup functionality for
every test we create a scope object this
scope object is going to be responsible
for keeping track of local variables
that have been created along with the
values that are set to now again here
are our shortcut functions which is just
mapping s to the set function on scope
and G to the get function on scope these
are just shortcuts so we're not
violating that rule we're taking
advantage of rule 5 then our first test
which instance it's that a scope which
works like a global context should be
able to set a variable in this case the
variable X to 1 and then with we go to
look it up with the G function it should
return that same value and if we try to
look up a variable that did not exist we
should get undefined back so in fact if
we run this spec we should see that it
fails well first off it says that scope
isn't even defined so first thing we
need to do we need to go to find this so
let's go over to this other file and I'm
just going to use the revealing module
pattern to keep things clean so I'm
going to create a scoping object and the
scope object it's going to expose it so
well
it's going to expose a constructor
called scope and this constructor isn't
really going to do anything it's only
going to create one instance variable
which is going to be underscored dick
dick for dictionary so this dictionary
is going to map from all local variable
names we know about to their values in
this particular scope this represents
just one scope so we've got that set up
let's run the specs now and see what
happens now we moved a little bit
further cannot read property bind of
undefined it's because we don't yet have
those get and set functions so let's
just go ahead and write those those are
pretty easy to write so get as you will
recall takes in the name of the local
variable we want to look up and returns
it so this is a simple property lookup
will look up in the dictionary the value
by the name of key and set is going to
be almost exactly the same set is going
to take an icky as well as a value and
then instead of returning it it's going
to set it to it nothing too unusual here
if we run this spec and I keep going to
the wrong window if I run it we now see
that our first spec which is a scope
that works as a global context should
work so awesome we have our first spec
passing and we have the concept of
global context which is not really
groundbreaking we've had that since x86
Fortran name any other language we had
this with registers so let's go a little
bit further we'll go to our next set of
specs so that was for global context now
we're going to enable this for what I
call a context so some of you may have
done some graphics programming before in
graphics programming whenever you want
to paint something you typically push on
a context you change the stroke maybe
the width the color a few other
properties and then you do some work and
then when you're done doing that work
you pop the context you do this so that
way the parent function that called you
doesn't get into any side effects
because of all the work that you wanted
to do in your own little function so
push and pop very often in graphics
programming would be called at the
boundaries of a function well in
JavaScript our functions do exactly that
functions act as boundaries between
different scopes so before we get to
that point we're just going to go ahead
and create push and pop functions so
notice we have two new aliases here and
let's go over and implement those
so hopefully now that we've enabled
these we should see that we have some
failing specs so it says scope for
context first off it says it cannot read
property bind this means that we haven't
defined those push and pop methods at
all yet so let's fix this will define a
push we're not even going to fill out
its implementation yet like all good
test German developers we want to make
sure our tests fail first and take it
one step at a time so now that we've got
push and pop we should see that some of
these tests look a little bit more
detailed now because now our setup law
can actually run and we have 12 tests
passing the first test is that the scope
should inherit variables from outer
contact sees well obviously at this
point we've only done global contact
sees so if you were to create a new
scope by doing a push that pushes and no
op so we're still in the global context
so of course we inherit variables from
outer contact seas and the last one is a
little bit more related to something
later on but will want to make sure that
one passes as well the first and third
tests are failing though it says that it
should be able to isolate variables from
outer context which means that whenever
we supposedly push a new context we're
leaking data into the external
environment because this at this point
we're only dealing with global contacts
sees we haven't implemented local
contacts ease and then the final one
variable shadowing this says that if we
have two variables of the same name that
if we set the variable by the same name
in the interscope it should not override
that when we go back to the outer scope
this is the isolation part so both of
these tests fail so let's go back and
actually make these sort of pass we're
going to set this dictionary which again
is a map from all the local variables in
the scope to its value and set it to a
brand new object and I'm going to cheat
here any time we go to pop of context
we'll just set it to a brand new object
as well let's see what happens now so we
have our first spec passing variables
are now isolated but we broke everything
else so we've taken a step backwards so
at this point we actually have to get
into the meat of this whole talk which
is going to be how are we going to make
scopes that can inherit variables from
other scopes because this is essentially
what happens enclosures a closure gets a
scope and that's go
has default values from the external
environment but if we go to override it
then we don't override the parents value
we actually create a new variable in
that scope so I use the word inheritance
on purpose that should trigger a certain
JavaScript concept in our minds and
here's where we get to the buzzword
prototypes what we want to do is we want
to create an object which inherits all
the default values from the parent scope
or the parent context at this point but
be able to override those without
influencing the parent the best way to
do this is we're going to use Douglas
Crockford method of prototypical
inheritance so whenever we go to push on
a new context instead of setting it to a
new object we are going to call a
mysterious method we will define called
fork this fork dick method will
take the current dictionary of local
variables and create an object which
inherits from it through the prototype
chain which means at any time we try to
do a lookup for a variable of a name
that was in a parent context we'll get
it but if we try to set it then we'll
get a completely new variable without
changing the parent so now that we're
calling for dick we should also probably
do something about pop because right now
pop is just creating a new object the
way we'll get around this is we'll take
a look at the current dictionary and
then we'll keep track later on with add
underscore parent will see exactly what
that means but dunder parent is going to
remember the object that will existed
before we pushed so let's go implement
that method will do it as a private
looking method so we'll do underscore
for dick it'll take in no arguments and
at this point a lot of you may gloss
over or some of you may be like oh I
know this pattern it's Douglas Crockford
method of prototypical inheritance with
a little bit of salt thrown in so we're
going to create a local variable here
and just assign it to the current
dictionary of local variables and then
we're going to start doing the pattern
which is we create a donor constructor
function we're just using this for the
prototypal chain this function will
never actually be invoked and then we're
going to set the prototype property on
this function to do this we'll use an
es5 feature which is object or creates
this does kind of another level of
inheritance but you could cut this all
as well it's just this saves me a little
bit of time so let's call object i'll
create dick
we'll set the functions prototype to
that now we need to set a few methods on
the prototype let's set the constructor
just because we're going to be nice
let's see instructor equals F and then f
dot prototype we need a way to keep
track of what the previous dictionary or
the previous scope was so we're going to
set that Dunder parent variable to
that way later on when we go to
pop we can go back to the previous
context and then to finish off Douglas
Crawford's pattern we just need to
return a function created by that
constructor so that was quite a lot
happening let's see if this actually
works which is why we have specs yes so
now we have our scope object and it
works like local contact sees kind of
like in the graphics idea a push and pop
now nowhere in your JavaScript code do
you see calls to push and pop you see
functions being created so now we're
going to actually implement that f
function we saw in the slides earlier
which will create a function expression
and assign it to a local variable so
let's go to our next set of specs will
disable those for now and we'll go down
to the next set just down here will call
these wolf call scopes that act like
this nested if ease so nested-if is if
you think about it our whole lot like
calling push and pop whenever you enter
a function you immediately get a new
scope which inherits from its previous
scope and as soon as you finish
executing that function and pop up the
stack then you get the previous scope
and that's like calling pop so in this
case we just want to use nicer syntax
notice that we found rid of push and pop
and we just have s G and F F is going to
be a new helper will write called funk
and then we have a bunch of specs
describing how this should work let's
see if this even works to begin with
well not at all it says cannot read
property bind we haven't even written
the funk helper so let's go give this a
try so recall that the funk helper or F
for the shorthand is supposed to take in
the name of the local variable to which
we want to assign this new function
expression it takes in a list of the
parameters by name that normally we
would put in the function and then in
between the parentheses and then it
takes that amnesic function body i'm
going to call it body here just so it's
obvious
that it doesn't have any memory of
anything else we're basically just using
functions as a way to get some code into
this environment but it doesn't remember
anything about its environment or where
it was created as it pertains to the
native scoping mechanism so in here only
to do a few things first off I know I'm
going to need to save the value of this
because we're going to call some methods
and then what I want to do is I want to
expose this function that's being
created as a local variable so I'm
calling this set and I'll set it to the
name that was passed in and then I'm
going to pass it in the function that I
want to set this local variable to now I
can't just pass in body if I pass in
body at this point body doesn't even
Remember Who its parameters are it
doesn't remember anything about its
scope what I really need to be able to
do is do a little bit of setup
functionality first in a wrapper
function and have that wrapper function
then call our amnesic function body so
will do exactly that will create a
function wrapper and in here we're going
to need to do a few things first off we
know we'll need to invoke body because
otherwise our code would never get run
but then we also need to deal with the
contacts sees we need to call push to
get a new workspace and then just below
it we need to do a pop now for this to
be really useful we need return values
so we're going to save off whatever the
body returned and at the very end return
that result this is pretty much it
there's one last thing we haven't done
though which is params notice we're not
using it anywhere params gives us that
list of local variables which get passed
into a function that's essentially
function parameters are just a
convenience on top of it well we want
that convenience so what we'd like to do
is after we've gotten a brand new
context we want to go over every
parameter and look in the JavaScript
arguments object that was passed into
this function rapper oops let's go back
where we were we want to set every
single local variable in this new scope
to all the values that were passing as
parameters that's going to be a lot of
code to type here though so I'm going to
create a little funk a little helper
this helper will take in an array of
params and a corresponding array of
parameter values which is going to be
arguments and I'm going to use the
arguments object here that JavaScript
provides to every function very
performant I assure you let's go a
little bit further
and let's go implement this arts helper
so we'll do proto scope args and it
takes in the names of local variables
along with their values and this is just
essentially a mass assignment operation
so we're just going to for loop over all
the names and then we're going to call
this thought set for every single one of
them so I'll names I and then values I
that was a lot of typing let's see if
any of this works it passes so now we
have our closure implementation working
whenever we build nested-if ease but we
have one last class and this is probably
the hardest class to deal with because
it will completely change our code and
break all of our assumptions so let's go
down here to the bottom to the last set
now if you look in here we've got the
same SF and G but you'll notice that
example that I wrote earlier which is
we're doing in outer function which
returns an inner function which returns
the values of x y and z and then we
invoke that function outside of its
definition contacts this is where
JavaScript's idea of closures becomes
very powerful is a closure remembers its
definition time scope not at execution
scope so let's see if this runs it says
it fails it says that it expected to get
3 comma 2 comma 4 but instead it got
three undefined for so this means that
somewhere we were accessing a scope we
didn't expect at least if we were
thinking this as regular JavaScript in
fact we made this error earlier if we go
back to funk look at where this dot push
is being called we're calling it inside
the function wrapper which means that
we're calling this stop push at the same
time we invoke this body not at the time
we define this function well recall that
this stop push is going to look at the
current scope and pork off of it so this
means that we're not actually keeping
track of the scope from when this
function was defined we're actually
looking at the scope and forking off of
it at the time the function is invoked
this is not at all how javascript
closures work in javascript it's based
on where you define the function
not where it's executed so to fix this
we kind of the this stop push statement
up a level we need to move it to the
time that we call our helper to define
this function but that's not quite it
either because as soon as we call this
not push it will change scope and we
don't want to change scope until we
actually execute the code so what we
really need is a way to keep track of
what the current scope is at the time
we're defining this function pre fork it
and then let that rest for a while you
need to save it off somewhere so that
way when this function does it get
executed it can resurrect that scope by
doing a scope push well let's just a
pseudocode this for a little bit will do
this and we'll suppose that we have some
way to get the scope for the current
closure and assuming that we get that
scope back which is going to be a scope
object will do fork which is just going
to be an inheritance now does anyone
start to feel a little bit uncomfortable
we're at 50 lines of code we don't have
this actually working yet and we have a
lot of functionality in this one scope
class or revealing module pattern if you
prefer this makes me uncomfortable we
have the idea of a scope which is
supposed to represent just one scope but
somehow we're supposed to keep track of
all the Scopes in memory so we can
assign it to functions that sounds more
like we need another class maybe so in
fact let's do that back in our tests I
preemptively did this we're going to
create a closure registry this closure
registry is going to keep track of all
the scope objects we create any time we
do a function it will collaborate with
all these different objects so at the
very top of our current file we're going
to create a closure regístrate will use
the same revealing model pattern so we
need to return the closure registry and
then we need to create our constructor
now this constructor won't take in
anything right now but it does need to
keep a registry this registry is going
to be essentially the entire environment
of our JavaScript runtime it's going to
map from all of the current functions
that have been created to their
corresponding scope some of you are
already thinking how are we going to do
that you can't use a function as a key
into a variable bear with me so we'll
set this up
and we'll need a way to keep track of
what closure is currently executing
we'll see just why in a moment so now we
can start moving some functionality
around push pop and funk really don't
belong here they really belong in a
closure registry because they all deal
with creating new scopes so let's put
that up here we don't really know how
push and pop are going to work in this
new context yet but we do know how the
function helper is going to work we'll
just change this out so its closure
registry and what we would like to do is
to implement this scope for current
closure method and then when we call
push instead of letting it fork off a
new scope at runtime we're going to pass
it in now some of you may be thinking
he's cheating he's using local variables
yes you can use local variables in the
implementation just not in your
consuming code that would be quite a bit
more difficult admittedly if not
impossible i have yet to explore that so
when we call this stop push will push in
that scope that we calculated at
definition time when we call the f
helper so we've got quite a few things
we don't really know about we don't know
how we're going to implement this scope
for a current closure we don't really
know how that's going to work yet and we
don't know how push and pop are going to
work so now is where we get a chance to
make a fun little observation whenever
our javascript is executing there's only
one scope active at any given time this
is a single threaded language so
whenever we enter a function we are
using the scope for that function seems
pretty simple so that means that
whenever we start a new function we push
on the active scope kind of like
contacts ease and as soon as that
function finishes we pop it off what do
we pop off back to whatever the previous
function was that called this function
we can guarantee this because we no
longer let people arbitrarily call push
and pop we always ensure that every
function calls push at the beginning and
pop at the end that means that we
actually don't need to keep track of
every function we've ever created and
map it to a scope we really just need a
stack of scopes so I'm going to turn
registry into an object or excuse me
into an array and this array is going
to keep track of what the current scope
is and all previous scopes at execution
time so that actually makes some of this
code a lot easier for example we know
that with a stack the current item is
going to be the last item so we'll just
index into whatever the current scope is
we'll look at the last item on top and
return it so now we have scope for
current closure defined now maybe we can
go right these push and pop methods
because push and pop will need to push a
brand new scope at execution time so
nowadays push is going to be taking in
the exact scope so we actually don't
need all this complicated fort dick
logic that's all going to be below and
we don't really need pop you know
someone might recognize these method
names and notice that I kind of saved us
a step push and pop these are methods on
a standard JavaScript array and they do
exactly the same thing as what we've
written here except that push pit takes
in an item to push so we could write all
these out in to be a lot of boilerplate
code but we can actually save ourselves
a few steps I've written a little helper
you can go check out the repo which i'll
post up later which is called delegate
it takes in a list of functions that
we'd like to create on the closure
registry prototype so that excuse me not
get set push and pop and then it takes
in a few other arguments it lets us say
we're to create these functions so i'm
going to say on the closure registry
prototype so it's just going to add
these and then I want it to delegate any
calls to those straight on to whatever
the current closure excuse me to
whatever the current scope is so call
this dot scope for current closure and
return that so again delegate is
basically just creating push and pop
methods for us on the closure registry
prototype but it just delegates to
whatever the current scope is which is
what is on top of the registry now
there's one other thing we haven't done
here we're still in our funk
implementation we're calling set and
args we're calling it on this which is
the closure registry it doesn't actually
have access to these methods yet they're
back on the scope well instead of
copying those over
be running an implementation here i'm
going to make use of my little delegate
helper again i'm going to delegate any
calls to get set and args straight on to
the registry and that should work so now
whenever someone in close your registry
tries to call get set or args it'll just
Selig eight straight on to whatever the
current closure is so this looks really
really close let's see if it runs now
cannot read property fork of undefined
well we had one other thing we forgot to
do so this means that scope for current
closure is at some point returning
undefined when we invoke it we don't
want that that's going to be problematic
that's because we start out our idea of
scopes and closures without a global
scope notice that the registry stack
step starts out empty what we need to
fix that all we need to do then is a day
starting condition which is going to be
to create a brand new scope and this is
going to be our global scope just to
start things off so we have a place to
attach all these function bodies later
on so we look really close to being done
but well we kind of reference this fork
function without defining it somehow I
think that's going to be problematic so
let's go on a little bit further and
just write this last method scope for
takes in no arguments and all it will do
is it's going to create a brand new
scope object so it is a constructor
absorbs and initialize it to a
dictionary using fork so this
just returns a brand new scope object
whose dictionary of local variables
inherits from this current scope but of
course our scope instructor doesn't take
in a default dictionary so we'll have to
do something like this so it can be
taken in that was a lot of code let's
see if it works nope not quite yet let's
see what we did wrong this dot
underscore registry dot length thank you
alright let's see what's going on now
cannot read property apply of undefined
let's see where our other issue is no
changes there do this Scott registry
that looks correct let's go for current
closure that looks fine when in doubt
check get
there's the issue
I swap these up a little bit
it runs so in let's see how many lines
of code this was 68 lines of code so in
less than 70 in 68 lines of code and you
can actually trim this down to 67 we
have our own implementation of local
variables enclosures in JavaScript so
you too can do this now some of you may
be asking can I actually use this where
would I go to use this and how can I
mass convert all my code over to use
this much more performant version of
closures well there's a transpiler for
it go to github github.com / nibbler
that's six continents / closures and you
can go try this particular demo online
where you drop in any code that use
variable assignments and lookups or
function assignments and we'll convert
it over to the appropriate code which
uses f SN g yes this is a transpiler it
is not doing regular expression math
substitutions so this should generate
usable code if you don't hit any of the
edge conditions that i explicitly mark
out so your next question may be should
i actually use this well javascript and
java script is a great way to get
brownie points with your next employer
so next time you're thinking about
writing some uninteresting legacy code
at your next job just so you can flee
from it later on drop in your own
implementation of closures and you'll
have guaranteed job security and then
your final question may really be is
this the future of performance
JavaScript and this is the first step
the next step is going to be to
re-implement prototypes with closures at
which point we'll get an even faster
tick in our benchmarks and the idea is
to use eval scripts to get this working
and I think the other one was to
completely drop out prototypes and we're
going to do that which is plain old
closures which are evaluating a script
so totally we're just going to swap out
these two concepts because prototypes
are faster closures and closures are
faster at prototypes so with that I
think you have all you need to make your
code much more performant thanks guys
you